STRETCH OF HIS INVESTIGATIONS ;
a
INTO FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD ;
.
SMITH HAS BEEN LOOKING INTO THE
POSSIBLE MISHANDLING OF
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS AND EFFORTS
TO OBSTRUCT THE 2020 ELECTION.;
a
NOW NOTABLE DEVELOPMENT THIS ;
WEEK, TIM PARLATORE, ONE OF ;
a
TRUMP'S KEY ATTORNEYS, ANNOUNCE;
HE IS LEAVING THE TEAM.
HE WORKED ON JANUARY 6th ;
a
INVESTIGATION AND PLAYED A KEY ;
ROLE IN THE MAR-A-LAGO DOCUMENTS
PROBE, INCLUDING ORGANIZING ;
a
TOWER, BEDMINSTER AND AN OFFICE
IN PALM BEACH AS WELL AS A ;
a
FLORIDA STORAGE UNIT.
PARLATORE ALSO APPEARED BEFORE
THE GRAND JURY FOR SEVERAL HOURS
BACK IN DECEMBER AND TIM JOINS
ME NOW.
TIM, THANKS SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE WITH US.
I THINK EVERYBODY WANTS TO KNOW
AFTER THE NEWS THIS WEEK, WHY ;
a
DID YOU LEAVE THE FORMER ;
PRESIDENT'S LEGAL TEAM?
>> SO, AS I SAID AT THE TIME, IT
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH THE CASE;
a
OR THE CLIENT.
THE REAL REASON IS BECAUSE THER;
a
MADE DEFENDING THE PRESIDENT
MUCH HARDER THAN IT NEEDED TO ;
a
.
IN PARTICULAR, THERE IS ONE
INDIVIDUAL WHO WORKS FOR HIM, ;
a
BORIS EPSTEIN, WHO HAD REALLY ;
TO BLOCK US, TO PREVENT US FROM;
a
DOING WHAT WE COULD TO DEFEND ;
GOT TO A POINT WHERE IT'S ;
a
DIFFICULT ENOUGH FIGHTING ;
AGAINST DOJ AND IN THIS CASE ;
a
HAVE PEOPLE WITHIN THE TENT THAT
ARE ALSO TRYING TO UNDERMINE ;
a
KNOW THAT I NEED TO DO AS A ;
LAWYER AND WHEN I AM GETTING ;
a
NECESSARY TO DEFEND THE CLIENT
AND ULTIMATELY WAS NOT IN THE ;
a
.
SO I MADE THE DECISION TO ;
a
>> INFIGHTING IS NOTHING NEW IN;
IS THERE ANY SPECIFIC INCIDENTS;
a
OF SOMETHING A HE DID TO, AS YOU
SAY, PREVENT YOU FROM BEING ABL;
a
TO PROPERLY REPRESENT YOUR ;
CLIENT?
>> SURE.
I MEAN, HE SERVED AS KIND OF A
FILTER TO PREENT US FROM GETTIN;
a
INFORMATION FROM THE CLIENT.
IN MY OPINION, HE WAS NOT VERY ;
a
CLIENT ON CERTAIN THINGS.
THERE WERE CERTAIN THINGS LIKE
THE SEARCHES THAT HE HAD
ATTEMPTED TO INTERFERE WITH, AND
THEN MORE RECENTLY, AS WE'RE
COMING DOWN TO THE END OF THIS
INVESTIGATION WHERE JACK SMITH
AND ULTIMATELY MERRICK GARLAND ;
a
IS GOING TO MAKE A DECISION AS ;
MERRICK GARLAND AS TO HOW BEST
TO HANDLE THIS MATTER, HE WAS
PREVENTING US FROM ENGAGING IN ;
a
>> YOU SAID THAT BORIS TRIED TO
PREVENT YOU FROM CONDUCTING
SEARCHES.
WHAT SEARCHES?
>> THE SEARCH AT BEDMINSTER
INITIALLY.
THERE WAS A LOT OF PUSHBACK FROM
HIM.
HE DIDN'T WANT US DOING THE
SEARCH.
AND WE HAD EVENTUALLY OVERCOME ;
a
.
>> WHY DIDN'T HE WANT YOU DOING;
a
THE SEARCH?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
YOU KNOW, BORIS IS -- YOU KNOW,
HE IS A LAWYER.
HE SPENT ABOUT 18 MONTHS AT A ;
a
WORK AND I THINK HE THINKS BASED
ON THAT EXPERIENCE HE KNOWS ;
a
>> YOU PREVIOUSLY TESTIFIED ;
BEFOR
BEFORE THE GRAND JURY IN
DECEMBER.
SOME PEOPLE SPECULATED YOU ;
a
COULDN'T REPRESENT THE FORMER ;
PRESIDENT BECAUSE YOU'RE A
WITNESS.
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE?
>> THAT UNFORTUNATELY IS A LACK;
a
.
FIRST OF ALL, I WAS NOT ;
a
.
WHAT THAT WAS SO THE ORIGINAL
SUBPOENA TO THE OFFICE OF THE ;
a
FORMER PRESIDENT, THEY WANTED A;
CUSTODIAN OF RECORDS TO APPEAR.;
a
AND ULTIMATELY THERE WASN'T ;
REALLY A GOOD PERSON ON THE ;
a
SO WE MADE THE DECISION, I MADE;
THE DECISION TO GO IN MYSELF AN;
a
TO FACE THE PROSECUTORS AND TO ;
ACTUALLY SPEAK DIRECTLY TO THE ;
a
T
.
SO AS I WENT IN AND I TALKED
ABOUT WHAT WE, AS A LEGAL TEAM,
HAD DONE IN SEARCHING ALL THE ;
a
PROPERTIES, THAT DOESN'T MAKE ME
A MATERIAL WITNESS OR ANYTHING ;
a
LIKE THAT.
SO THERE IS NO CONFLICT.;
a
EXPECT TO EVER BE CALLED BACK IN
THERE.
IN FACT, THERE WERE A COUPLE OF;
a
OPPORTUNITIES WHERE I OFFERED T;
COME BACK.
THE PROSECUTORS DIDN'T WANT ME
BACK.
SO IT REALLY HAS NOTHING TO DO ;
a
WITH THAT.
>> SO YOU RECENTLY SENT A LETTE;
a
WITH THE OTHER ATTORNEYS ON THE
LEGAL TEAM TO THE HOUSE ;
a
SELECT COMMITTEE ON
>> YES.
>> ONE OF THE ARGUMENTS YOU MAK;
a
IS THE REASON THE DOCUMENTS ;
E
ADMINISTRATION, PARTICULARLY ;
a
SPECIFICALLY YOU SAID THAT THE ;
FACT THAT THESE ENDED UP AT
MAR-A-LAGO IS, QUOTE, INDICATIVE
OF THE STAFF'S PACKING PROCESS
AND NOT ANY CRIMINAL INTENT BY ;
a
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE PROBLEM IS, THE FORMER ;
a
ALL PUBLICLY CONTRADICTED THAT ;
ENDED UP DOWN AT MAR-A-LAGO.;
a
AT LEAST FOUR OFFICIAL
EXPLANATIONS THAT THEY HAVE PUT
DOWN ABOUT THE STATUS OF THESE
DOCUMENTS.
I WANT TO GO THROUGH THEM
CHRONOLOGICALLY.
STARTING AFTER THE SEARCH ;
a
WARRANT AS EXECUTED AT
MAR-A-LAGO SOME OF THE PRESIDEN;
a
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS SO THAT THE ;
WHEN HE REMOVED THEM.
DID YOU EVER SEE ANY EVIDENCE O;
a
ANY SUCH ORDER?
>> I NEVER SAW THE ORDER.;
a
YOU KNOW, THAT WOULD NOT BE ;
.
I DIDN'T SEE THAT.
>> SO THE FORMER PRESIDENT THEN
A COUPLE WEEKS LATER SAID THIS ;
a
.
>> IF YOU ARE THE PRESIDENT OF ;
a
DECLASSIFY BY SAYING IT'S ;
ABOUT IT.
>> SO THE LETTER SAYS THAT HE ;
a
SHIPPED TO MAR-A-LAGO.
HOW CAN YOU DECLASSIFY SOMETHIN;
a
WITH YOUR MIND IF YOU DON'T KNOW
THAT IT'S IN ONE OF THESE BOXES?
>> THESE ARE TWO UNRELATED ;
a
CONCEPTS.
SO THERE IS THE ISSUE OF
CLASSIFICATION OR
DECLASSIFICATION.
THAT'S SEPARATE AND APART FROM
THE ISSUE OF DOCUMENT MANAGEMEN;
a
AND WHAT GOES IN THE BOXES.;
IN THE WHITE HOUSE, IN THE OVAL;
a
OFFICE, THEY DON'T MATCH THE ;
SAME LEVEL OF, YOU KNOW, CARE,
IF YOU WILL, THAT ARE DONE IN ;
a
.
AND SO MARKED DOCUMENTS, WHETHER
CLASSIFIED OR KEY CLASSIFIED,
AND UNCLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS GET
MIXED IN.
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT WHEN ;
a
PACKED UP TO LEAVE.
THIS IS ABOUT THE FOUR YEARS
WHILE THEY ARE IN OFFICE.;
a
NOW, SINCE WE SUBMITTED THIS ;
LETTER WE FOUND OUT THAT THE ;
a
ARCHIVIST TESTIFIED THAT EVERY ;
ISSUE.
THAT'S WHAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THERE.
SO THE PROCEDURES FOR
DECLASSIFICATION IS A SEPARATE ;
a
PACKED AND HOW THE DOCUMENTS
WERE KEPT DURING THAT FOUR ;
a
.
>> NOW, WE KNOW FROM CNN ;
a
ESPECIALLY HOW MUCH YOUR FORMER;
CLIENT NO
KNEW AND UT
THE PROCESS.
A FELLOW ATTORNEY WHO SIGNED
THIS LETTER TOLD ERIN BURNETT
EARLIER THIS WEEK.
>> HE IS AWARE OF A BUREAUCRATI;
a
AT THE END OF HIS PRESIDENCY HE
RELIED ON CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITY AS COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF
WHICH IS TO TAKE DOCUMENTS AND ;
a
TAKE THEM TO MAR-A-LAGO WHILE ;
DECLASSIFY AND PERSONALIZE THEM.
HE TALKED ABOUT DECLASSIFYING ;
a
THEM BUT HE DIDN'T NEED TO. ;
TRUMP FOLLOWED THE PROCESS FOR ;
a
END OF THE PRESIDENCY HE DID ;
NOT.
DOES THAT CONTRADICT WHAT YOU ;
a
GUYS TOLD CONGRESS?
>> IT DOESN'T BECAUSE AGAIN WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT DOCUMENT
MANAGEMENT, NOT
DECLASSIFICATION.
AND WHEN IT COMES TO ALL THE
DECLASSIFICATION PROCEDURES, ON;
a
THING YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER, WHE;
YOU GET A SECURITY CLEARANCE, ;
a
.
PRESIDENTS DON'T GET THAT.;
a
ELECTED OFFICIALS, THEY DON'T
HAVE SECURITY CLEARANCES.;
a
MATERIAL SIMPLY BY VIRTUE OF THE
FACT THAT THEY WERE ELECTED.;
a
SO WHEN YOU'RE THE PRESIDENT, ;
YOU ARE NOT ACTUALLY GOING IN ;
a
ENTRIES TO DECLASSIFY SOMETHING;
STAFF, HEY, THIS DOCUMENT HERE,;
a
.
THEN YOU KINDA TAKE IT WITH YOU.
NOW, SHOULD THE STAFF HAVE ;
a
FOLLOWED CERTAIN PROCEDURES?;
.
BUT AGAIN DECLASSIFICATION ;
a
PROCEDURES IS ONE OF THE THINGS;
THIS LET EARLY.
AND IN FACT I PUT A FOOTNOTE IN
THERE THAT WE WEREN'T DEALING
WITH DECLASSIFICATION, SIMPLE ;
a
STORE AND WHAT NARROW PROCEDURE;
THERE ARE UPON THE
ADMINISTRATION CHANGE WITH THE ;
a
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT. ;
>> SO WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS.
RECORD CREATED DURING THE ;
a
THE GOVERNMENT AND SHOULD BE
RETURNED AND CLASSIFIED.;
a
LAST QUESTION BEFORE WE BREAK ;
FOR A MINUTE.
IS THERE ANY EVIDENCE THAT THE ;
a
FORMER PRESIDENT DECLASSIFIED ;
THE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS THAT ;
a
WERE FOUND IN THE BOXES?;
WHAT THOSE DOCUMENTS ARE TO BE ;
a
ABLE TO CHASE THAT DOWN.;
SO ONCE DOJ GIVES AN INVENTORY ;
a